Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors, this presentation we're going to go over histamine
For those who don't know anything about it. Hopefully this will be helpful for those who already know that they have a histamine issue
This will help explain it a little bit that it's not a disease and it's not an allergy
You've had heard it that it's a histamine sensitivity
Well, we're going to get into details of that in this
presentation, so hopefully you'll get a lot out of this so stick with me
So the first thing that we want to understand that is that histamine does a lot of really important things in our body
It helps us produce hydrochloric acid. It helps us
Kill things as an in an immune response
That functions as a neurotransmitter. It helps us get to sleep and stay asleep. It helps other hormonal functions in our body
It acts similar to an adaptogen in our body
It helps us keep memories in the brain. That's the neurotransmitter piece
It helps us wake up. We need histamine to stay awake
histamine is a very important substance in our body. It's from a classification of organic
substances called amines
So histamine is made by our body. It's made by
massed cells in our body
in the presence of an
antigen
Like an infection mass cells release histamine. It helps us kill that infection
It's an important factor in a lot of different cellular function. The thing is it has
Doesn't have a very long half-life in our body. So it shouldn't stay present in the tissues for a long period of time
So the question is is histamine good or is histamine
bad? Just like every other substance that is made in our body or that we absorb it into our blood stream
It's really not about whether it's good or bad. It's like you heard about cortisol
Well too much cortisol can cause you to retain fat and so cortisol is bad
Well if you don't have cortisol in your body, you won't break down sugar stores
And you won't be able to stay sleeping at night and cortisol is not a bad guy
It's a hormone that's secreted during the stress response by your adrenal glands
Histamine is not a bad guy either. We tend to think when we have a histamine reaction or we have
histamine sensitivity that histamine is bad
And we want to get rid of all histamine in our body. Well, that's just not really true
It's all about balance. That's just the way our body works
It's all about made-tady balance and keeping the right amounts of everything in our body
That's just like what we talk about the genetic picture
When I have a genetic defect I don't I don't create enough of something or I don't make enough enzyme to break down
Something and I could have excess one thing in two or two little of something else
It's all about trying to maintain that delicate balance
So we want to always classify something as good or bad, but that's just not really true
We need histamine the problem is is sometimes it's difficult to maintain that balance and if this is what you feel like
On that balance beam of histamine that we could have some issues
So how do we get out of balance? How do we maintain that balance?
So that's what this presentation is for. So let's talk about that
So we have to remember in made-tady that histamine balance that histamine is produced by
Intubued response. So if I have an excess
Abued response due to something. Well, how could that be?
Well, if I have chronic Lyme disease or I have a hidden chronic
H. Pylori infection or I have a hidden
Mold sensitivity because I have molded my body or some hidden parasite in my body
So I have this chronic
Ramped up immune response in my body. I am going to be producing excess histamine
So some people say oh, I have a histamine tolerance because I make too much histamine
Well, you better figure out why you make too much histamine. There's no imbalance
That's genetic of you making too much histamine. The reason why a person would make too much histamine is that they have a
Chronic usually some clinical infection meaning that they don't know they even have this infection
For instance, we've talked a lot about H. Pylori and heart disease. The first incidence of
knowing the person has a chronic H. Pylori infection is that they dropped out of a heart attack in a post-boredom study
That blood smear of that clot reveals in H. Pylori infection. Well, we didn't even know they had that
Death could be the first indicator
But there's hints. What are the hints of a chronic infection is a
histamine issue?
So you could have
histamine problems because of a ramped-up immune response number one
Doesn't have to be a ramped-up immune response as you'll find out in a second
But that is one reason why a person could have excess histamine and they find themselves out of balance
The second way that we get histamine at our body is through dietary sources. So a dietary source of histamine are
basically aged foods
Cheese, aged cheese the older the cheese it is the more aged it is the more histamine it's going to contain
eggs contain histamine so again
How old the eggs are how old the histamine is going to how much histamine levels they're going to be
Nuts all nuts contain histamine fermented pickled foods obviously those are aged they contain a lot of histamine
Alcohol contains histamine aged meats smoked meats contain histamine
Well, wait a second you're gonna say
Gosh, I thought fermented foods were really good for me. They have all sorts of probiotics in them
I've been making kombucha and water kefir now you're saying that that's not good for me
Time out a second there. So understand
histamine is it a bad guy? There's nothing wrong with eating histamine
It's all about balance
So if I have a histamine issue that we're going to talk about these foods
If a person doesn't have any issue with histamine they could continue to eat these things
Now obviously you want to know if you have antibodies to dairy and you should be eating cheese
Or if you have you know candida and you shouldn't be eating fermented foods either
So there's all about balance we tend to in this society think that oh kombucha's good for you
So everybody should eat kombucha everybody should eat fermented foods
That's not what you're going to find always true
So we want to see where the balance is
So if a person has excess histamine levels that you want to look at number one do they have
And a ramped up immune response for some reason
i.e. a
subclinical infection or number two do they are they eating too much dietary histamine
And this is going to be something else going on with that like a leaky gut or a gene defect that we're going to talk about in a second
That's allowing these histamines to pass through and causing a ramped up histamine in the tissue
Remember it's all about balance
So keeping that balance is is the key even with a person with a high histamine level
It's not that they have to eliminate all these high histamine foods
They may want to cut down on them for a while to decrease the histamine in the body and then they can still eat these
We're not talking about an allergy
So get that difference
We're talking about a gluten sensitivity that's an allergy you're having in an immune reaction to that gluten
We're not talking about an immune reaction to histamine
We're talking about what histamine does to the tissues and when we eat a lot of histamine foods with a leaky gut
Or with the inability to break down histamine
Then those go into the tissue and we have an excess about a histamine in the tissue if you could think of
Of a bucket that's that's my best scenario think of a bucket
Okay, wrong bucket. We don't want to think of that bucket think of an empty bucket
So here's an empty bucket that
Is your tissues when we're talking about histamines
Now all sorts of things go into that bucket and when that bucket gets full and spills over we have an issue
So when we eat foods foods go into that bucket and they have a lot of histamines in it
Well, we fill up that bucket if we have a chronic infection and our mass cells are making a lot of histamine
We fill up that bucket. So even if I I have a cold. Oh my goodness. I have a cold
So by cold I'm going to produce more histamine than if I did it have a cold
If I have any any
Committed
Faction that I might be going through for just a short period of time. I'm going to have excess histamines
If I have a histamine problem and I have a cold
Maybe I should eat less histamine foods so that I don't spill over my bucket
Follow me
This is why people that have histamine issues go
I can't figure it out. I ate eggs four times this week and I didn't have any issues
So I was trying to figure out which food is causing my issues
What could what issues could histamine cause?
Racid heart
bloating tummy tummy aches stomach problems digestive issues
itching
rashes
eczema
rosacea type issues
Or all histamine issues
foggy thinking
Brain fog anxiety depression emotional swings can be histamine issues stuffiness a nasal congestion can be histamine issues
So I'm trying to figure out is it a food allergy and it's just so confusing because
I ate eggs four times this week and then I ate eggs this morning and I know right after I ate those eggs
I felt so cruddy by stomach bloated up like I was pregnant or whatever symptom is causing your thoughts
to
To conserve yourself with a possible food allergy understand it's not a food allergy
It's the it's the chemical histamine. It's this amine in this food
That's fill it up your bucket and finally tipping over now you have the symptoms of this excess histamine
Got it? So it's not a allergic reaction. It's just a bucket spilling over
So let's look at some of the genetic factors that predispose us to histamine issues
When we look at your genes, there's really two gene families that we want to look at with histamine issues
That ABP1 gene and that HNMT gene
These genes or these families of genes are the two most important things with the histamine issue
The ABP1 gene really makes the enzyme that the DAO enzyme that breaks down histamine in the gut
The HNMT gene makes the DAO and the MAO enzyme that breaks down histamine in the tissue
So if in this case, there's actually I could get all the family of the HNMT gene
Here, this is what a 23 and B panel reads out
Five of the APP1 genes and about 20 of the HNMT genes
In this person's case scenario that I
Took the screenshot of this is a person's gene profile
They have two single allele defects in the ABP1 gene
They're going to have a decreased production of DAO enzyme in the gut
And therefore any food that they eat that has histamine in it is not going to get broken down
Quite as well as if they didn't have those gene defects
Follow me
So this is a gene profile
The ABP1 is a gene, a family of genes that you see here
That one means that person has a single allele defect
Two of those family genes
That family of genes, those ABP1 genes
Single allele defect is going to cause that gene to not quite work so well
So therefore, what does that gene do?
That gene makes DAO enzyme that breaks down
histamine in the gut
So they're not going to break down histamine quite as well as if they didn't have this defect
Therefore, they could absorb more histamine
Therefore, they could have an excess histamine in their body
Well, in this person's case scenario, it gets much worse
Because they're H-A-N-M-T-G
They have a double allele defect
Just what I showed here, they actually had a worse picture than this
But I had a double allele defect on
Five, a four of those six that I showed in this picture
Now that's really bad
So that gene is not working very well at all
So even if they get a common cold, they're going to have a ramped up histamine level
That's normal, right?
The common cold is going to increase histamine production
That's normal, but normally histamine should have a very short half-life
Why?
Because this wonderful H-N-M-T family of genes
should be making DAO and MAO enzyme that should be breaking down the histamine
So that this person doesn't have any excess histamine
But in the case of this poor soul that has this gene defect
They don't make that very well at all
So in the tissues, they don't get rid of histamine
Well, that kind of stinks
So now they're going to have
Their bucket is going to fill up quite quickly
So even if they don't eat any histamine foods
And they don't absorb any histamine foods from the gut
Which is really relatively impossible
I'm just saying pretend
They're still, if they get a common cold, they're going to have a spill of histamine into the body
They just don't get rid of it very well
So they're going to be prone to problems with histamine
So from a genetic standpoint
These two genes make the enzymes that break down histamine in the gut and in the tissues
If you have defects in those two gene
Families you are going to have problems with histamine
Well, it gets worse than that
Because there's another gene, the FUT2 gene
That makes the healthy slime layer for your microbiota to live in the gut
So your flora can live in the gut so that you have this healthy
Sibbiotic
A micro, called your microbiota
All these different bacteria and organisms that live symbiotically in your gut
To help you absorb food, help you break down food
And they live off of you
And you live off of them
Now FUT2 is a gene that helps make the apartment complex for them to live in
This poor person has a double allele defect of the entire family of the FUT2 genes
They don't have any carpenters making the apartment complex for the gut flora to live
They're going to have a much damaged gut flora
So you heard a leaky gut syndrome
Well, leaky gut syndrome ties into that
So a person could have leaky gut syndrome because they took antibiotics for three months
And though they killed all their flora and they have to take probiotics to regrow that flora
But if you add a FUT2 gene defect to it
And they took antibiotics for three months
And now they take probiotics
For the next six months to try to re-heal their gut
That's the person that I can't figure out why my gut is still got such a problem
I know I shouldn't have taken those antibiotics for three months
But I've had taken probiotics for the last two years
And they don't do anything
Well, let's look at your gene profile
And golly Jeepers, you got an FUT2 gene defect
Well, you're not going to get better period
And let's give you pre-biotics
And we do a bunch of their stuff to heal your gut
Still with me?
So this histamine thing's a little bit more complicated
Maybe you have been once led to believe
You have to look at the genes
The ABP1 and the H&MT and the FUT2 gene
It's very important because it really tells us the story and how we're going to fix this person
So this is why I'm so keen on doing your genetic testing
The immune response is going to ramp up
My histamine release
It's going to fill up my bucket
Any chronic immune response
Right?
Or in acute immune response
It's going to fill up my bucket quickly
Dietary intake of excess histamines
It's going to fill up my bucket
Because even if I have a really healthy gut
And no leaky gut
Still, lots of consumption of histamines
If I'm on a salami and cheese
Good diet
I'm going to have a lot of histamines in my gut
So, they're going to absorb
So even if I have a healthy gut
Some are going to be absorbed
It is going to fill up my bucket
Well, if I have a healthy ABP1
And a H&MT gene
I make it plenty of enzymes to break it down
It's no big deal
I'm not going to have a histamine problem
And that's the majority of people
So 70% of the population maybe I just
Pick that out of the air
Don't have a histamine problem
Because they don't have a gene defect
And they can handle it just well
Then you had a leaky gut on top of that
Because this person was exposed to
Genetically modified organisms
And they eat a typical American diet
Or they have a taken antibiotics
Or whatever that damage the gut
And a FUT2 gene defect
And though you got a
Chronically ill individual
Follow me
You add all these things up
And it gives you the picture
Of this person having a histamine intolerance
So, what do you do?
That kind of stinks
Well, you're stuck
No, I'm just kidding
So, there are some things you could do
So, let's just think this through
Just think it through
And everything that we talked about so far
Well, does it make sense that we should
Work on healing the gut?
Yeah, well, we don't want to absorb
You know, excess histamines
So, maybe we should work on healing the gut
So, that gets back to
You know, healing the gut is a very important thing to do
The better if you've got kids
Or a Lyber, headaches
Or whatever you got
Healing the gut is really important
So, how do you heal the gut?
Well, you want to
Reduce inflammation of the gut from other sources too
So, does this person have a gluten sensitivity?
Do they have a dairy sensitivity?
Do they have
Parasite infection
Do
Is there something else
At H. Pylori infection that we need to kill in the gut
Well, I talked about ramped up inflammation too
And ramped up immune system too
And it increases
Bass cell production of histamines right there
But, you don't want to deal
Try to heal the gut
Causing inflammation by eating gluten
When you have a gluten sensitivity
You're never going to heal the gut, right?
Well, we already talked about eating
Less histamine foods
So, less H. G's, eggs, dots, etc
I got a whole list of these things
That we give our patients that have histamines issues
That I get it's not that
That's an allergy
It's that these are foods with high histamines
So, it would be a good idea to reduce those
For a period of time until we get your gut healed
Until we get your bucket down a little bit
But, I love pickles
Well, you could still eat pickles
But, maybe don't eat quite so many
Maybe make sure you eat a lot of fiber with your pickles
And maybe you balance it out
Think of that bucket
We don't want it to overflow
How else do you heal the gut?
Well, there's a bunch of different nutritional things you could take
I'm really big on prebiotics
If you don't have the, especially if you have the H
The FUT2G defect
You've got to use prebiotics
Or you are toast
These are the people that are on probiotics for four years
And they say, I can't figure out how I can't heal my gut
Well, you're probably depositing the probiotics
In the toilet every day
Because you don't have any place for them to live
So, prebiotics help your gut cells
Make the apartment complexes for the probiotics to live
You could say
Also, you helping with HCl and digestive enzymes
And increasing your stomach acid, production, etc
There's a whole bunch of things we want to do to heal the gut
And you have other presentations on that
But that's really important and that's a good place to start
The other thing is reduce systemic inflammation
What's causing my increased mass cell production of histamine in the first place
Right?
Better look at that
Do I have a chronic infection that I don't even know about?
Do I have H?
By the way, do I have Lybed disease?
Do I have Ball?
Do I have some parasite of some kind
That I don't even know about
How would I know that?
There's labs you could do
There's Tasty you could do
We do that in our personal lab tests
Our crazyology testing of every patient
There's lots of ways to know that
Just because your doctor did a blood test
And the blood test didn't show Hpylori
Does that mean you don't have Hpylori
It's not going to stay in the blood for very long
Okay, same thing with Lybed
I had a negative Lybed test
What'd you do?
A blood test for Lybed
Did it test fray at day bodies?
Uh, no
Well then, it was a pretty lousy test
Because Lybed isn't going to be circulating
Your blood for very long
Or you're going to be dead
So, you got to go to a doctor who knows something too
So, uh, look at my videos on all that stuff
This is this video
This, um, is not a chronic infection
But chronic infections are rare bit
That it's a cause of a lot of people's problems
So, just, just know that
The other thing you could do is to
Use products that will help scavenge
Uh, histamine out of your body
Um, this first one, this Seek It Health product
Is histamine block
That is actually the DAO enzyme
And there's a number of
Companies that make that and supply the DAO enzyme
I don't suggest using that a lot
First of all, the DAO enzyme does not absorb
So, it's only going to stay in the gut
Well, that's okay, right?
Because if I could eat, if I eat some cheese
Then I take the DAO enzyme
Then it'll break down
And I won't absorb it
Yeah, that is okay
But, it's kind of a pricey product
It's about a bucka pill
So, I'd suggest that's not the way to go
No, granted if you
What? Displurge
And you know your bucket's full
Then you could take a few of those
All of my patients with histamine issues
I have them by a bottle of that
But then try to have them
You know, not use it
You know, you could use it in an emergency
If you know, you're going to go out
And have a lot of histamine foods that you were exposed
A lot today, you're under a lot of stress
Stress increases in two
Then you can take some of that
There's other histamine scavengers
Like designs for health histories
We use a professional health product
Called histamine scavenger
That works really well
I need to have a picture of that
And you could use a life-aimus stress reduction
Can't just start begging your head against the wall
That always helps
Maybe not
So, remember that it's a bucket
That's the biggest thing I want you to get out of this
Because I said that word probably 500 times
The more that you put in the bucket
The more symptoms you're going to have
You're not cursed to not be able to eat
Cheese, eggs, nuts, fermented foods etc
The rest of your life
But the more you eat
The more you're going to put in that bucket
The more symptoms you're going to have
Many times it's good to just
Clean it out
Figure out these problems
Heal your gut
And then you can go back and experiment
And see how much you could tolerate without having symptoms
Does that make sense?
Again, if you're watching this
If you've never done it, the genetic test
Go to my website there
The Connors Clinic website
Go to the genetic tab
And you'll learn how you could
Run the genetic test on yourself
And even if you're not a patient
I'll still read the test for you
And we can go over that
That's the best way to look at this
I think that's super important
Anybody that's been told that the hemah
Histamine hypersensitivity
They're really working hard
Stayed away from histamine
Foods really should do the genetic test
It's not that expensive to find that out
That's what we do with all our patients
Because you really want to personalize their medicine
It just goes back to balance with everything
Remember, you know
Just because kombucha is really good
Does not mean it's really good for everybody
And just because histamine is
Not good for you
Because you have excess histamine
Does not mean histamine is bad
So you want to personalize your care
And how you're going to treat your disease
As best as possible too
I hope you learned something from this
Go back and watch it
To get if you need to
And enjoy some of the other videos
On our site as well
Thank you
Have a great day